c'est raconter l'histoire de
téléspectateurs on t'a fait une surprise
on t'a fait une blague
y'a pas que c'est le cas bien compris qu
il lance des douilles balance qui
valorise mars qu'est ce qu'ils aiment
aussi big three
moi je te propose qu'on balance à
magnéto qu'est ce t'en dis alors parce
que j'ai vue mercredi après j'ai vu sur
les réseaux sociaux il ya plein de gens
qui disaient il ya big flo et oli dans
le public il paraît que vous étiez dans
le public
bref très roulante a fait une surprise
on s'est caché dans le pays dans le
public est à rien qu'à tallinn on
l'était pas non plus hyper bien déguisé
faux pas c'est vrai ce que vous n'avez
pas dû croiser mon regard intrus cobas
non tu verras nous a pas regardés bas
matin dans tu rigoles c'est bien tu
verras parce qu'il m'a dit ça tout à
l'air de réaliser ouais mais c'est bon
moi je vous aurais capter direct avant
et je vous le dis j'ai vu il était dans
le public et j'ai vu des photos après
deux dans le public grimés chili mais
avec cheese aurait eu les matches et
sait qu'elle est directe voir nous
aurait cramé dire
oh
[Musique]
olala produits
je m'appelle dédié je suis agent
d'assurance j'ai 43 ans ça fait cinq ans
que j'ai ouvert ma propre agence
je m'appelle césar directeur du festival
latino américaine à toulouse et à flins
et après le maillot aujourd'hui raju le
dit on est sur plein de dossiers dans un
instant on
on parlera thierry ghillani comme tous
les jours un regard celui qui se
présente à la mairie de paris
je sais qu'il ya des pluies diluviennes
dans le sud où se rendent les comptables
sans nom tombent directement d'ailleurs
soir des choses c'est ma nouvelle tout
est savamment série
mais partout mais regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mettez la photo la photo à croix c'est
vrai parce que tu ne gagnes pas tu avais
tu as beaucoup trop gentil tu vas dire
comment tu t'appelles humilié sympa mais
les gens qui connaît pas ça c'est vrai
mais quand on est allé dans la loge tout
est là tu as fait mais les gars je vous
aurais capter direction on a fait des
photos avec tout l'équipement car c'est
un hymne devise alors très honnêtement
quand je me suis rassis je me suis dit
ils disent quelque chose ça doit être
des habitués de l'émission a dit que
c'était à moi de me parler mais hyper
sympa et nous savons comment ça va ça se
passe bien je dis oui au top tu vois les
photos que les deux gars pendant que
derrière il avait grillé il ya quelques
personnes du public qui avait grillé et
avec quelques chronicles aussi qu'il y
avait beaucoup avaient pas demandé de
c'est le pianiste moi que tu nous as
grille alors les chéris c'est vrai que
mine de rien pour moi je vous trouve
avant pour voir les tetes s'il vous
plaît parce que c'est vrai que mine de
rien voilà watch mais c'est vrai que
vous regardez vous ne regardiez pas dans
les yeux mais il est mauvais joueur
on peut on peut au tna mais en plus
quand tu es dans quand tu es concentré
dans la migration doit pas dire mais
nous on était caché derrière sa lancée